snow and ice are wreaking havoc from
ohio to the rio grande
much of the u.s now gripped by severe
winter storms
the states of louisiana missouri
kentucky and texas have all reported
deaths
amid historic freezing temperatures in
north carolina and georgia
storms brought tornadoes across the rest
of the nation
millions are without power as rolling
blackouts continue
this is sad this is a sad state of
affairs i wish it were better but
you know somebody's got to do some
planning after all this is over
and make sure there's an alternative
source of energy texas is bearing the
brunt of the ark to
chill with power outages forcing people
to use warming centers
families desperate to keep warm have
taken to lighting fires
in sugarland texas authorities believe
that's what killed a grandmother
and her three grandchildren just
incredibly tragic
a young woman 41 years old
family children it just doesn't get
worse than that
seniors too are struggling as care homes
run short on medical essentials like
oxygen for those already concerned about
their parents amid the covet crisis
it's a worrying time if we weren't here
i can't imagine
because there's really not a lot of
information flow the rolling blackouts
in texas have led to criticisms over the
state of existing power grids
many residents are calling for
alternative sources of power
others say that's a conversation for
another time
this week we have to get warmth i mean
people are losing homes they're losing
food they're i mean you've seen i'm sure
that people have died so it's like we
should
concentrate on that first and then maybe
figure out the solution
next week so it doesn't happen again the
severe weather is hampering efforts to
get people vaccinated for covert 19.
but forecasters say another extreme cold
front will affect south
and central parts of the u.s in the days
ahead
andy gallacher al jazeera